hi in this short video we'll talk about
endospore staining
now many bacteria especially that of
bacillus genus
forms endospore in harsh environments
and endospores are resistant to heat and
harsh environmental situations and they
can survive in this situation for very
long
and this particular endospore staining
method actually determines bacteria that
forms endospores
because of their tough protein code made
up of keratin spores are highly
resistant to any type of staining method
so they won't take up gram staining
so the primary stain that is used for in
endospore staining is malachite green
which is highly penetrant
so at the end of the staining what you
would be seeing that these bacteria that
has produced endospore would be stained
in green
whereas the other vegetative bacteria
that doesn't form endospore would appear
something pinkish
in this video it would be clear what is
the basis of staining and why
these kind of coloration is generated
so the step one is as usual smearing on
the slide you would take some amount of
the culture and put it on the slide and
smear it then in order to fix them on
the slide you can heat it quickly and
briefly and all of these bacteria would
be now immobilized on this slide it
would be easier
in staining procedure then we have to
add the primary stain in this case the
primary stain is malachite green
alternatively in some cases people also
use carbol fusion which is used for acid
fast staining anyway the point of using
carbol fusion or malachite green is both
of them are highly highly penetrant an
endospore wall is almost
impermeable to anything
so in order to penetrate
we need to use a stain that is highly
penetrant such as carbol fusion or
malachite green
anyway
carbol fusing would easily penetrate
in the cell walls or in this endospore
wall
and
once we add malachite green we wait for
some time for incubation
such that the stain gets in but honestly
this stain would not get in very easily
that's why sometimes we have to put
these slides on steam
steam would
help these stain to get inside the
endospore wall more efficiently so we
have to steam it then the step is
decolorization
again we'll be using a decolorizing
agent here to wash these
stains
now in this particular situation
the bacteria that had
that that didn't have endospore
they would not retain the stain
the decolorizing agent would actually
wash away all those malachite green from
those bacteria and it is actually
soluble in water so it would be easily
wiped out
but the endospore staining would be
retained because once the stain has
entered that endospore wall it's very
hard to wipe that stain out and take it
out
so while counter staining with safranin
only the vegetative portion of the cells
would be colored as
pink or like reddish color that is why
we are going to see this characteristic
appearance in our microscope we are
going to see the vegetative cells in red
and generally we are going to see this
spherical
staining of endospore
in that
so all the notes are provided in the
description and you can find more notes
and flash cards in my
facebook page
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support me on patreon my courses
are also present in an academy you can
use my code ip10 to get a 10 percent
discount thank you